something you taint it forever what is
the difference between a taint and a
grundle grundle and not for me tell my
daughter well all right hey jackie uh hi
a grundle a gooch a taint a nifken are
all the same these are all references
i've never heard of nifken yeah the area
between um your testicular uh holding uh
area and your anus is a uh that's a
nifken a grundle lagooch a taint
um are any of those like
medical terms or are they just all uh
they're all
they're all medical terms depending on
what doctor you go to those are all
medical
it depends on if you go to an urgent
care or cedar sinai right cedars they'll
tell you
uh taint
right urgent care here in the valley
grundle grundle
wow yeah
i had no idea and women don't have uh
they don't have that area it's not
that's not what it's called it's not
what's it called
jackie jackie
what's it called what's it called
between
on a woman there is actually an is it
the framium the uranium
it's either the cranium or the uranium
yeah it's definitely not uranium you
should you should get uh you should be
clear on what it is
because you don't want to be around
uranium yeah that's right does anybody
know what it is between the vagina and
the anus
sean i'm going to look it up i do
research that's what i do we do research
during the show i saw that she was doing
research during the show live and she
was frustrating you i could tell
well i don't know if it frustrates me as
much as it frustrates the audience
because i'm listening to a podcast
nothing's going on they must be
researching that she is this is a
podcast
anyway
perennial perennium for men perennium no
but perennial perennial isn't perennial
meaning when you're having a baby yeah
it's also called perineum perineum
that's the area that's between your anus
and your tissue located between the
vagina and the anus is the not a
perennial perennial it means it's
doesn't that happen every year or it
happens for the rest of you flower the
perennial is the flower it is yeah the
annual perennial
well jackie always gets the area between
her vagina and her anus mixed up with
flowers
it's one of the same what is it
what it's perennial perennium or
perineum
no no no there's a hernia i see there
was a perennial but it's a perennial
it's a perineum perennium what's that
what's that word there
uh perennial
oh lasting a lifetime oh you you now
change the the the search to flowers
yeah
no let's get out of the garden and back
into the groin that's right yes which is
also a garden nonetheless perineum see
perennium or perineum can you use the
word in the sentence
the perennium in humans that's what it
says in humans in humans yeah where else
would you because in animals it's called
something else okay the parenting you
keep changing the in humans is the space
between the anus
and the scrotum in the male or the
frenulum labiarium pudendi that's what
it is i forgot that word padendi padendi
it's a frenulum labiaram padendi
frenulum laborium padendi i think i've
got an itch on my fernium but but stop
with that
for those that don't know go back to the
penis they're on yeah caroline caroline
is uh why is it bent why is what bent
the penis is bent there that's dangerous
that's a perennium no the the penis
there the drawing is bent that's
actually a medical condition it's really
sad oh there is a condition where it
turns to where you're always signaling
yeah to the left what's that called when
you have a bent oh you have that no no
but this is what you this is what it is
i thought you were just holding up your
hand no this is if you're making a left
or a right turn you know this in old
traffic signals you'd stick your arm out
the window right and this is if your
penis is bent you have to do this when
you when you when you meet a woman you
have to go like this to go my penis is
bent
do you have to tell a woman before that
you're jackie don't you have to tell a
woman but doesn't a man have to tell a
woman if his penis is bent
no and it's called it's called a wrong
hey talk about good
i have a half poodle have peyronies i
have a perennial oodle
so that's uh poodles a poodle knees a
poodle knees which means your penis is
bent into the back of a poodle that's
exactly right right
[Music]
you